the rematch of Barty Crouch Jim Barty
Crouch jr. yeah I figured I acknowledge
that weird coincidence of of those two
actress from Harry Potter facing off
again and this hey overdue Doctor Who
review we are up to the first two-parter
of series 2 that brings us to rise of
the Cybermen and the age of Steel so I
am probably gonna go off on a bit of a
tangent about the Cybermen specifically
so let's hold off on that we'll come
back to it the first thing is you need
to be prepared for the campy or aspects
of Doctor Who to kinda really come to
the forefront in this one I mean to be
fair the episode does clue you into that
basically right off the bat with lumic
saying right before he has a a proto
Cybermen kill his his assistant I guess
yeah when his assistant says oh well we
have to alert you know the Geneva
Convention or whatever and then lumic
goes and how will you do that from
beyond the grave but like especially
coming off the heels of some of the
really great performances and you know
in something like draw on the fireplace
or our school reunion god you compare
our Anthony Stuart heads you know very
restrained but very menacing performance
to this Wow so if this is this is pretty
campy as far as modern era Doctor Who
goes so if that's not your bag that's
gonna be a big problem I've gotten
better about rolling with it for the
most part it's still not my preferred
sort of angle for Doctor Who to come at
things but I can roll with it so we've
got the whole parallel universe thing
which honestly
I would have annoyed me except that I
really like how it's handled within this
episode and then how the series as a
whole is handle it because normally the
introduction of something like parallel
worlds would really make me very worried
about future storylines because it's
such a it's such a rabbit hole of
retcons and bringing back old characters
and bringing back alternate versions of
dead characters you know it it's the
kind of thing that enables a show with
not the proper restraint to become very
masturbatory and and instead of giving
us new stuff instead giving us all these
alternate versions of stuff we already
had I'm like what I want no stuff it's a
big universe show me more of that not a
whole other one so thankfully the show
never really did that and I think a lot
of that comes down to how it is
approached here which is that it's made
very clear that they should not have
been able to get here it was a fluke the
fact that they are here the very nature
of this universe may mean they can't get
back and once they leave they shouldn't
be able to come back now obviously we
know they do mate there are a couple of
more stories that come up and use this
parallel world thing but they never lose
sight of the fact that like this should
not be happening it's never easy which
is good because then it never takes over
the story which is especially good
considering that the show's already
dabbling in time-travel which is another
thing that can be a big rabbit hole for
these kinds of shows to fall down
thankfully it's a central part of Doctor
Who premise so it already handles that
pretty well um I actually think Tennant
is a little bit of a backbencher in this
episode nothing he's bad he's fine and
he's got some he's got some nice little
moments as it goes along but I think
it's because there's so much that has to
happen we have to establish this entire
parallel world how it works the players
in it the characters roses got our whole
thing with Pete and then there's Mickey
and actually I think from me Mickey's
the highlight of the set of this
two-parter I really really enjoy him in
this I mentioned in the last one oh my
the girl in the fireplace that I kind of
wish making it stuck around a bit more
and I really like this dynamic dynamic
he not only is he becoming a better and
better and more enjoyable character as
he goes along there's also a sort of a
little bit of sadness in the fact that
like he knows if any situation requires
the doctor to choose between him and
Rose the doctor is always going to pick
Rose and Mickey knows that and that that
does give a nice kind of layer to things
especially with his awareness of it and
so I like that quite a bit naturally
he's got a moment where he goes to visit
the parallel universe equivalent of his
grandmother died and I also mentioned
this last week I'm if you can hit me the
right way I choked up with not a lot a
lot of effort and I did choke up when he
goes to see her because his grandmother
in his universe you know she died
because she fell down the stairs she
tripped going down the stairs and he
looks past the doorway past her and he
sees the carpet up a little bit on the
stairs and he he says how I told you you
got to get that fix and he's choking up
saying that and like I felt the lump and
I'm like oh God
Mickey and so I really liked is it's
down to performance no Clark gives a
wonderful performance and he has been
giving so many layers to this character
as he goes along I'd say he does the
same with Ricky except Ricky is kind of
OneNote I think by design though because
Ricky's gonna die so you know we're left
with with the better version so you know
that that works okay
the roses whole thing with people first
of all I like having feedback because I
like Pete he's a good actor he's likable
he's really good sort of writing that
line of being like you're a little bit
of a weasel but I kind of like yeah and
I like how the dynamic is just different
enough from what went on in father's day
that it doesn't feel completely
repetitive and redundant because it's
not a you know you can't see him because
it screws up history it's a you can't
see him because
he doesn't know you you have no place in
this universe this is not your Pete you
are not his Ruth he doesn't even have a
rose I mean the dog but you know what I
mean
so I it's just enough of a shift in that
dynamic that I don't mind kind of
revisiting some of that stuff also
probably part of the reason I don't mind
visiting it is that element of Father's
Day was very good in an episode that I
otherwise actually don't really like so
maybe that's part of why I don't mind
having it come back because it was the
best part in an episode that I don't
like anyway
so all of that is working really well
and there's a lot of interesting details
supporting cast is is solid I like this
is more I mean I always always kind of
like the feisty possibly dangerous older
woman I've always enjoyed that I love
her like oh this is the slowest getaway
in history and like she's got this
homemade EMP bomb like oh it's nice it's
a shame she dies but it's good I I like
her a lot
but okay yeah it's not for me to deal
with the elephant in the room which is
the Cyberman themselves now when I first
watched this you know back in the day I
I just didn't think too much of the
cyber in one way or the other I thought
oh okay they're a little like the Daleks
gimmick slightly different but they they
felt very similar they had us they had a
one-word catchphrase that they would say
before they kill someone instead of
exterminate we get delete and you know
so it felt very much cut from the same
cloth but now going back and read
watching it now and having a much better
understanding of what the Cybermen are
or more importantly what they can be
when used correctly I really don't like
the Cybermen I feel like they miss that
this iteration of the missus a handful
of really key components because the
Cybermen are just scary they're tragic
and the tragedy of a society whose
members
possibly reluctantly but ultimately
voluntarily become what the Cybermen are
simply because they they value survival
staying alive above all else including
their own humanity that lends an air of
tragedy to it and I think that is lost
when they are the creation of one madman
who just programmed them to go out and
convert other people so instead of being
something that the Cybermen do because
with their emotions gone because it's
the only way they can function because
otherwise everything hurts too much
that would their emotions gone they
don't see the problem in converting
other people to be like them they lack
the empathy to understand or care
whereas these Cybermen it feels much it
feels that they these Cybermen feel way
more like robots than the Mondas
Cybermen do and also I want to be clear
like I'm not saying every single
instance of classic era Cybermen were
perfect they weren't all and sometimes
that wasn't great either but Cybermen at
their best are not robots like very
distinctly not but these feel a lot more
like robots than the Cybermen should I
feel and because what this ultimately
feels like is this rather than a human
kept alive through artificial means way
past the point where they should have
died and is a distinctly different beast
from a robot with a human brain for a
CPU because ultimately that's that's
what these Cybermen are I will say that
like my distaste for this particular
iteration of the Cybermen Cybermen is
alleviated somewhat by the fact that
this is all in a parallel universe so
creating this different version of the
Cybermen or the cybus men if you will
does not in any way negate erase retcon
the original mon das version I mean even
though we were stuck with this version
on the side
for a while in new whoo I do like that
in introducing this alternate take it in
no way erased the old version which I'm
really appreciative of especially now as
I've gotten to know you know again how
good classic Cybermen can be with things
like tombs of the Cybermen with spare
parts with world enough in time so
having you know having all that
background now the Cybermen as new who
depicts them at this point go from being
a fine a little generic to actively
irritating me because I know how much
better they can be and have been in
other iterations so and then there's you
know just the the random little things
like I don't like I don't like how loud
their stompy boots are like again I get
that they're going for like like a scary
militaristic stomping kind of thing but
I don't love it so oh and can we mention
the fact that it's that the title for
the first part of this being rise of the
Cybermen that was really dumb because if
you look at the episode the way that
it's structured seems to be around the
idea of we're going to hint that these
are gonna be the Cybermen will have a
silhouette will have what Jackie Tyler
gets taken over for a bit by looming you
know the thing comes out her ear pods
and it connects and it's that Cyberman
shape and so it feels very much like the
episode is put together in a way that
was intended for classic era Doctor Who
fans to catch it but then the real
reveal comes later
except you put Cybermen in the title why
would you do that also and there's the
completely weird moment that like I
don't I guess they try to go for just
weird juxtaposition with homeless people
getting chopped up and put into Cybermen
bodies to the tune of the lion sleeps
tonight I don't know it's not the first
and it won't be the last time that
doctor who gets weird with music uses I
mean
mean immediately made me kind of
flash-forward to to the master taking
over the world to voodoo child like wow
why why and it's also funny to come back
because I remember people mentioning I
think it was especially with Rosa or
mentioning general series 11 even with
the trailers people like oh the pop
music and I'm going back and watching
these and thinking baby new I'm not
saying you it gets a pass because of
that cuz I don't like it here but like
that's not a new thing she's been doing
it for a while so I think they'll wrap
up on that night I think I hit
everything I wanted to hope so so rise
of the Cybermen in the age of Steel what
did you think about whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff that you can do because there's
buttons and links there's one to my
patreon if you're feeling generous a
whole bunch of links besides peel barks
etc it's all down in the description
check out if you want to and if you
don't you know what that's okay because
at the end of the day you're the council
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]